hi my name's Christina I'm a sophomore
at UCLA my name is Salani and I am a
science teacher hi I'm Ryan I'm a
teacher I teach primarily math and
English I'm the hall I'm a third year at
UCLA i tutor NOAA USDA also tutor at
UCLA this is teens versus teachers
taking the same geography quiz who's
smarter oh I think I'm a C in geography
I'm not really I mean I know the general
map of the world and places but I don't
remember doing that great class I would
give myself
c-minus I think I could pass but it's
like bare minimum passing so we'll see I
don't want to build myself up too bad
and look like an idiot so I'm okay at
geography I'm not gonna geography at all
I'm probably gonna get a zero or
negative score I'll believe in yourself
students in the US are terrible at
geography I'm a student in the u.s. I'm
terrible at geography I think that in
the United States we don't do a very
good job of teaching anybody about
anything outside of our like particular
bubbles and it's kind of like jarring
and alarming coming from like being a
student LAUSD we were really focused on
like sciences and math so like if you
asked me where Chicago is I have no idea
like honestly I feel like New York isn't
office inside of Chicago so you know
coming from me we never really stressed
that in school so are you ready I'm so
ready darling okay what are three of the
five major inhibited US territories
inhibited can I get a addiction
inhabited I'm skiing how I said
inhibited see that already fail I got
one I'm like trying to interpret the
term territories it could mean a few
different things I feel like so I'm
trying to think like what they mean by
major inhabited US territories and
there's also connotation there of their
being uninhabited US territories so my
mind's going there but I don't think
there are any of those I don't know I'm
getting too deep yeah you got a lot out
of that question I was like I'm trying
to get the first one down here on the
paper next one what is the world's
smallest country by area into Tulsa City
yeah this is you guys are tricky there's
a lot of small countries it's not the US
that's that's a continent yes I have an
idea but I don't know if it's exactly
right but it's gotta be close
let's go on to the next one which of the
following US states has the shortest
coastline Alaska California Florida or
Maine oh my god
those all sound like they have ample
coastline yeah okay
all right there's a trap door here
somewhere I just I can't find it Alaska
I feel like is like 3/4 covered with it
yeah like it's surrounded rather yeah
California so like long and narrow it
seems pretty long but Florida is like
got the wraparound you know I guess if
you've straightened that out would it be
longer than California's I don't know
and then man that's you know get into
the Northeast I don't know a lot about
that area
okay what is the capital of Turkey
that's it yeah
this one I'm pretty sure I know all
right we're on the same page maybe we
both got one point hope I'm right what
are the official language of Brazil no
that's amazing
yeah okay hopefully oh yeah oh my god I
spoke too soon there could be a trick
there what what's the official link of
the United States of America English
there isn't one
goddamn okay yeah I think I don't name
four countries that border France I
gotta like close my eyes and like
envision a map let's see is it bad if I
don't know Frances I would say it's not
good I don't know anything I really
don't know anything can you name the
continent that Frances on did better
than some people would okay I'm just
gonna name any countries I know in the
same continent what country would you
find Mount Kilimanjaro Jordan Kenya
Tanzania or turkey I know this one I'm
gonna do just a little trick that I
teach kids it's called process of
elimination we're gonna say not that one
I don't think it's that one okay how
many countries have elected or appointed
a female leader before the United States
there's definitely so many before the
United States we're so behind at least
one right I can imagine it I don't own
the other country I have a good answer
for this but it's not the answer they're
looking for so I'm gonna go with it okay
honestly I didn't do too well on this
out let's see I feel terrible I don't
think I go one right I haven't been in
school for a long time and I teach a
specific subject so so how much do you
rate I'm grating myself on a curve so I
got like three of them what about you I
gave myself in a curve I've ever gotten
three here okay
so it's a game okay I got one and a half
points I got one and a half oh yeah ha
ha
so who's smarter Donita one and three is
a good number we're tied yeah I'll learn
geography by traveling and having the
ability to go to these places where I
will look at the map I am this one I
don't think that's gonna teach me
anything but I will look at it even if I
don't look at it my students are gonna
tell me here this is what it is in the
cloud so I'm also upset that I got only
two countries around France since I've
been to France so I am a dumb-dumb I
didn't really defense and I got through
so the lesson here is never go to France
and you'll know more about it yeah I
feel like I definitely missed out on
geography for sure I need to travel more
but as a teacher I don't make enough
money so if I can get a little raise we
can find out all these countries and
borders and all that [ __ ] I need to be a
flight attendant for a year boom that's
it you look like a flight attendant I do
look like that's what my mom told me but
I would have to seek my nose piercing
okay
[Music]